hello there gizmo is now playable in
multiverses and with a new character
comes a ton of new moves most
referencing back to the gremlins movies
in the 1980s and 90s the plan today is
to show you all the references i've
found and a few easter eggs in gizmo's
move set and a little about the story of
gremlins so expect a few spoilers along
the way we have to start with the epic
dance emote gizmo has back in the 80s a
scientist found him on the street and
took him to a lab where they discovered
well see for yourself
[Music]
he likes
[Music]
he doesn't get away this time a
reference i'm sure you've already
noticed is the box gizmos brings out of
each match it's from the original film
and was the box gizmo was actually
smuggled out in to get out of the store
he lived in he was a gift to this guy's
son billy at christmas time his fearful
look is seen regularly in the movies as
he hides away like in the gremlins 2
poster and an animated version for the
video game
gizmo's first ultra tire is a nod to
rambo at the start of the second film he
sneakily takes the tv remote and starts
to watch rambo who has explosive arrows
and by the end of gremlins 2 he dresses
up like john rambo complete with bow and
arrow the great thing about this attack
move is what it's made from there's a
mini montage of gizmo training before he
crafts a bow from a paper clip and a
rubber band
and then an arrow from a pencil antipex
which google tells me is called
correction fluid in the us he then uses
a match to light it and takes out a
freaking gremlin that is a spider honest
truth if you haven't seen the films
spider gremlins are real and this whole
concept with the explosion is the reason
why gizmo can light popcorn on fire with
his arrow the up attack move sees gizmo
throw popcorn into the air the funny
thing is he never eats popcorn in the
movies but the gremlins do tons of the
stuff the only reference i could find to
this is the movie poster where gizmo is
inside stripes popcorn gizmo's down
attack move lets him bring out a
keyboard when billy and the mogwai are
getting to know each other they try to
transpose gizmo's song into piano notes
gizmo gets involved on the final note
before falling into a bin dressed as
santa claus oh and you know the santa
hat version of gizmo is definitely
coming to the christmas update of
multiverses on a side note there's a
couple of easter eggs here whilst
playing that piano it's possible for
gizmo to save these two lines
[Music]
so gizmo knows both the king of pop from
the 1980s and beethoven my guy has a
well-rounded musical education
the other musical performance in game is
the mogwai's song the little dude blasts
it out a few times in the movies and it
always gets attention
what's he doing
singing
he does that sometimes
in game the notes aren't the same
they've probably been changed due to
copyright reasons it's a pretty iconic
tune and i doubt i can play it without
being copyright struck myself
[Music]
so gizmo has a sports car in the most
masculine of colors pink in game he can
run over enemies which is pretty strong
and will likely get nerfed soon in the
movie just like the rambo reference
earlier on gizmo watches racing on tv
and wants to try it himself and finds
the opportunity in a toy store no less
he roots around until he finds the toy
car this was created to look as close as
possible to barbie's dream convertible
car i found the original commercial for
it it's a bit old now hot shy anyway
back to gizmo racing over to stripe the
reason why the car can randomly take
flight in game is yet another nod to the
movie travelling at speed gizmo hits a
snow shovel and flies into the air just
like in game he then lands and takes out
stripe by opening a blind and letting in
the sunlight and as we all know stripe
is coming to multiverses soon to get his
revenge gizmo has the ability to latch
onto teammates and follow them around
like he's in a backpack due to his size
he's always being shown shoved into
things in gremlins from bags to
toolboxes to cages and of course
backpacks too to emulate that he can
briefly sit on the shoulder of a
teammate and blast out all his moves sat
on a lantern this time i guess this is
the homage to chinatown where he
originally lived offensive stereotypes
were big in the 80s the very best thing
about doing this though there is a small
chance that gizmo will sing this
do you recognize it it's new york new
york
and if you've seen gremlins 2 you'll
know that one of those creatures gets
the ability to speak i think there are
some fascinating ramifications here for
the future and sings new york new york
with countless other gremlins saying
these things out loud sound weird but i
promise you they are true
[Music]
like all the other characters gizmo has
unique win and loss animations when
losing he'll get back in his box and
cower away but the winning emote has
more to offer gizmo kicks back with
popcorn 3d glasses and enjoys some tv
just like in gremlins what makes this
extra impressive is the clock behind him
it's almost midnight and if he eats past
midnight he'll become a gremlin and yeah
i did try wait here for five minutes to
see if he ate any of that popcorn after
midnight but as you can see the minute
hand goes back so no there's no hidden
secret here when playing as combat gizmo
his loss animation sees him a little
upset while standing on a box which
happens to be where he got the paper
clips from to make the bow and his
winning animation looks to be another
rambo nod as he eats by a campfire a
cool change is using toast on a pencil
instead of meat on a knife even gizmo's
falling animation is a reference to the
movies he dropped through the sky just
like that time he accidentally fell down
a hole in the ventilation system
[Applause]
[Music]
gizmo's royal dodge has been seen a few
times before usually in video games in
the movie though it was used to show
this mogwai's reveal a face only a
mother could love back when games were
2d in all 1980s the gremlins 2 video
game 4 amiga had rolling attacks for the
bad guys and to be a little bit more up
to date in another warner brothers
multiverse game lego dimensions gizmo
has this devastating roll attack bye-bye
and finally a reference i'm really
struggling with the umbrella obviously
it's there to stop gizmo getting wet as
that will make him produce other mogwai
and multiply but i couldn't find any
visual evidence of him using an umbrella
in movies or games but there's a ton of
artwork depicting gizmo with an umbrella
and it makes sense he'd carry one you
know just in case but i wanted more info
so i went down a well of despair on
google and looked up other rainbow
umbrellas warner brothers have been
linked to before and the only one i
could find is from doctor who could this
be a subtle nod to that franchise coming
over i mean they're in lego dimensions
at least or maybe i'm trying to read too
much into this it's an umbrella time
will tell so how did i do did you catch
a reference i missed please let me know
in the comments i'm adam you're awesome
i'll see you next time
[Music]